ich sehe viel energie und taschen und
das ist mir die kirche wurde als ich
ankomme habe es mir unser
generalsekretär gesagt mach es doch
einfach so nur lose laufen um sie
schnell umzustellen das ist mir nicht
nur das interesse der schweiz an einer
friedlichen welt das steht ja schon in
der verfassung und die nachhaltige
entwicklung ebenfalls
sie ist die erste frau an der spitze der
die zack mit so viel drive ist wohl
keiner ihrer vorgänger gestartet
[Musik]
ausbruches vorstehen dazu noch nie
gesehen ganz bringen und das ist ja für
schiffe sehr gut dann kam ihnen mit
arbeitet mit reduzierter kraftsport
gemacht und das ist immer toll und das
kam so noch
[Musik]
sport macht ist super ja es ist gut der
ist nicht im ruf am morgen aber wenn ich
vor allem schnell
sie wollen seinen triumph ja es ist auch
sehr sportlich ist die gesundheit sport
mit der sache vor ihrer berufskarriere
hat es patricia dunn sie als
siebenkämpferin bis an die olympischen
spiele von atlanta geschafft
[Musik]
wenn ich mir die ziel gesteckt haben
kann ist eigentlich meistens erreicht
ich habe gemerkt dass sie schnell
karriere
aber so nach aachen ich hoffe ich tun
kann als der durchschnitt und kann es
sehr gut kann auch bis fokussieren und
denn wenn sie müsse sie eigentlich mehr
leistung bringen auf abruf sozusagen
sich zu freuen und verlor
wenn es wirklich zählt oder wenn sie
wickeln muss sie dass das denn effektiv
dass irgendwer eine energiequelle und
hielt auch die ganz klar hätte ich
einfach nur noch energie und nono
meistens gute idee oder bessere idee
sogar das sind einfach cool
der bundesrat holt patricia dunn sie die
frau die sieben sprachen spricht vom
internationalen roten kreuz in die
direktion für entwicklung und
zusammenarbeit
sie ist die erste frau an der spitze der
dcc hat sich im selektionsverfahren als
beste kandidatin erwiesen
grazie vielen dank für ihr vertrauen ich
freue mich sehr diesen posten übernehmen
zu dürfen und ich garantiere mich voll
und ganz dafür zu engagieren
im ios beta die frau die antritt um not
und armut zu lindern demokratie zu
fördern und menschenrechte einzuhalten
trifft auf eine gigantische
gesundheitskrise genau wieso scope hobby
vielen krisen atv darf mal betrifft es
die kommt sie auf einer seite corona hat
sich bei der tour in afghanistan mit dem
bankerin in new york
und dass es sich ganz speziell im ersten
amtsjahr bestimmt die pandemie inhalte
und form der arbeit
treffen wir hier in der genfer mission
sind selten
danke danke dass sie sich zeit nehmen
hier eine karte für sie soll ihre zur
neuen position
ich freue mich sie zu treffen
die haben viel gemeinsam mehr als wir
glauben
austausch mit internationalen
organisationen ist wichtiger bestandteil
von patricia tanzis arbeit des surf zb
widmet sich der terrorismus prävention
wenn sie perspektive geht verliert wenn
sie hat job and wenn sie keine
perspektive sind für die familie besucht
denn hat sie war man mit ali aber das
rra sie dass sie sich den organisationen
zu wandern so das versprechen
und es ist wichtig und die organisation
gemacht dass alternativen und zwar für
junge leute dass sie sich nicht mit
terroristischer organisationen zu
wandern
dass sie in zukunft sind für sie die
familie im stunden takt geben sich
vertretende verschiedene organisationen
die klinke in die hand
der klimawandel und seine folgen gehören
aktuell zu den schwerpunkten der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit der dpa
ich bevorzuge physische treffen mit
sticks man kommt ganz anders in kontakt
von überall auf der welt erreichen die
studierte umwelt und agrar
wissenschaftlerin ähnliche
erfahrungsberichte nur so viel ich noch
nie soviel krankheiten noch nie soviel
überhaupt um fast jeder ort und wieskau
von extremen lage
richter und verzerrt und das heißt dass
der planet als solches eine extreme
situation ist sie waren auch
olympioniken das ist lange im
laufschritt geht es über mittag zum
hauptsitz des internationalen roten
kreuzes 25 berufsjahre auf der ganzen
welt verbinden patricia dunn sie mit dem
ikk und viele freundschaften dominique
stillhart ist ein wegbegleiter der
ersten stunde im ikk auf ihrer ersten
mission in bosnien haben sie sich
kennengelernt
die mitglieder machen wir mittags mit
einer un-organisation modell kein genie
war international bergauf und dann
haben sie doch mal butter hätte man
selber york dann haben wir nämlich sind
meetings mit dem zusammen was mich immer
rechts bmw druckpapiere showprogramm zu
machen und dieses mal traf war in
bosniens klar ist wir sie einfach immer
extrem ruhig news wort und so einfach
ganz natürliche autorität ausstrahlt und
das hat ihre extrem viel nützt natürlich
deren arbeit und im druck mehr auf ihn
ausgesetzt sind in humanitären
organisation
sie ist einfach extrem belastbar also
was sie alles um 3 uhr bringt ist
wirklich schluss
[Musik]
es gibt gewisse dosis von bescheidenheit
sich das muss ich hoffe das hat zwar nie
aber dass man sich wirklich nicht
wichtig nimmt das zu seinem umzug kommt
hauptsächlich und dass man versucht
klinische gestrige bringen und dafür
stetig und jeder tag
ja ich finde es sensationell deshalb
momentan erfahrung auf dem niveau
vertrackter und was sie halt einfach
extrem gut wenn der vor allem mit der
heutigen zeit ist das partizip
verschiedene kulturen verankert ist und
für die arbeit wo mehr macht und was sie
jetzt bietet er macht ist das einfach
total wichtig weil sie ein ganz
spezieller zugang zu vielen
verschiedenen liebt und das ist gerade
während extrem ich die eltern haben
patricia dunn sie gutes rüstzeug mit auf
den weg gegeben
ihr nigerianischer vater ist in fribourg
doktorand in rechtswissenschaften ihre
mutter angehende sekundarlehrerin als
sie zur welt kommt von der mutter hat
sie das humanitäre engagement vom vater
das diplomatische geschick
moskau aufgewachsen in der region zug
wird patricia dunn sie oft auf ihre
herkunft angesprochen ihre hautfarbe ist
schon in früher kindheit thema mein
erster tag im kindergarten hatte aus dem
zweig hinter rossi andere sind mit denen
hug dachte ich auch das unternehmen im
ihk dass ich das alles bin ich relativ
sie und dan ist nur ein junge burg wo
ein behindert ich keine zweite ich sie
vor deinen beete wo sie gemeint und der
diskussion
ich fahre aber ich kann jetzt kriege ich
bin in einer opferrolle laxey sondern
probiert ein kostensituation aus jeder
situation zu sagte der fr es positives
gesehen und ausmachen und positive als
frau ist dass man fünf polnische impuls
leben und in der arbeitswelt wenn
diversität kryptisch und die ist immer
dann hat man in ihrem vortrag nach zehn
monaten endlich die erste auslandreise
im neuen amt
mit dabei ein reporterteam der schweizer
illustrierten profit bestimmt den
reiseplan beraten
an der seite ruth huber am chefin des
bereichs aus zusammenarbeit der deetzer
20 stunden busreise nach sarajevo liegen
vor ihm
es ist eine rückkehr an den ort ihrer
hochzeit und ihres ersten einsatzes als
ikk delegierte sehr viel emotionen
ganz europa im kontext dass er nicht nur
in brüssel sondern auch in serie
das ist speziell sich mit seiner mission
macht das land regiert hätten
pöltens zurück und gespannt was das
alles löst aber ich bin gespannt wie es
aussieht
nach 24 jahren
[Musik]
ich probiere immer werde mich auf eine
preisklasse dem land vor dem kontext
erzählt und am besten roman
einstimmig versetzt und auch nie anders
notiert recht und man versucht soll ist
ich bete und hoffe aber das geschäft auf
und versucht über die aktion zukunft und
immer wieder menschlichkeit im
vordergrund rückte bis sehr schlecht
getreten
[Musik]
das ist gut für das land
wird das gerne busfahrers dafür wie groß
das ist toll
die reise führt durch italien slowenien
kroatien nach bosnien
[Musik]
unterwegs immer wieder fahrerwechsel
auf dem balkan rücken
kriegsvergangenheit und migrations krise
in den vordergrund
[Musik]
eine mitarbeiterin der botschaft
empfängt die reisegruppe
dann trifft die grenzregion weniger
lautstark über genannt
[Musik]
der krieg in den 90er jahren hat spuren
bis in die gegenwart hinterlassen
[Musik]
patricia dunn sie erinnert sich an die
situation kurz nach kriegsende was man
nicht versteht sich von der stadt
bombardiert diese erste paar tage mit
der bevölkerung das trauma politik das
wirtschaftlich sehr wahrscheinlich zum
teil bewegungen und mit gesenkten
ausbauprojekt oder das auto
das ist sehr lang und das verarbeiten
nach 20 stunden reise ankunft im hotel
in der hauptstadt
[Musik]
mustafa sarajlic und patricia dunn sie
haben vor 25 jahren zusammen für das ikk
ingo rasche gearbeitet
als wir zusammen gearbeitet haben hatten
wir noch keine familie
und jetzt sind die kinder beinahe
erwachsen
[Musik]
als ich nach sarajevo kam warst du schon
hier der meisten die fahrprüfung genau
demselben ort im selben auto und ich
sagte ich arbeite in garath der und du
sagtest ich auch was für ein super da
sind wir ja du hast viele selber der
macht nicht schön euch alle zu treffen
bist du groß und wir werden immer
kleiner
patricia wie geht es dir gut mir geht es
gut
gehst du noch job als er heute
angekommen sind die journalisten haben
es nicht gemerkt ich auf der terrasse
mit dem springseil nur so um mich zu
bewegen
lasst uns überraschte sprechen
patricia war sehr bekannt in gora
sterben sie jeden morgen joggen gehen
sie war eine athletin wir waren
fasziniert dass sie mitglied des
olympischen teams der schweiz war
wir waren jungen aus einem kleinen dorf
das gerade aus dem krieg gekommen ist
das war schon speziell
speziell für uns aber im grunde ist es
nichts im vergleich zu dem was wir in
der folge realisierte wie groß wie groß
herz und seele sind dieser frau die
damals noch patricia nadler hieß
[Musik]
er hat keine richtige schwester hätte er
eine müsste patricia sie seien
deine großmutter hat mich sozusagen
adoptiert
sie lässt er ausrichten sie vermisse
dich das ist ungefähr zur zeit als wir
uns kennengelernt haben ich muss dir
dieses foto zeigen ein trauzeuge bei
unserer hochzeit im casting genau 23
jahre jünger waren wir aber auch
delegierte und den gelöschte haben wir
geheiratet
die behörden hatten immer noch die
jugoslawischen formulare
nach dem krieg waren wir die ersten die
in gerechte geheiratet haben mit dem
neuen formular
[Musik]
ihr erster einsatz hat eine starke
verbindung zu land und leuten geschaffen
[Musik]
die wunden des krieges sind in der
region bis heute präsent
die arbeitslosigkeit ist riesig die
abwanderung groß insbesondere die junge
generation ist desillusioniert
die deetzer unterstützt gezielt projekte
die helfen alte strukturen und
hindernisse wie etwa die korruption zu
überwinden besonders vor junge leute zu
motivieren einfach für eine sache von
mitte sich dem system und toten jungen
menschen eine perspektive bieten das
will dieses start-up unternehmen
lassen sie mich die herausforderungen
schildern
alle werden sich dafür interessieren wie
wir mit diesen umgehen und wie wir die
probleme lösen wollen
ich glaube die jugend von heute haben
die hoffnung verloren und wir glauben
wenn sie wenn die jugend hier eine faire
möglichkeit hat sich zu entwickeln
jobs zu finden jobs zu machen dann
werden wir eine neue hoffnung kriegen
dann werden wir eine neue zukunft für
bosnien herzegowina wieder haben mit der
wirtschaft bosnien herzegowinas geht es
auch ein vierteljahrhundert nach dem
krieg kaum aufwärts über zwei millionen
menschen sind seither abgewandert
doch eine neue generation weckt hoffnung
diese jungen menschen setzt die data in
einem projekt als botschafterinnen und
botschafter ein
die schweizer botschaft hat uns junge
als erster ernst genommen und gemerkt
dass wir konstruktive ideen haben eine
neue generation die sich keine grenzen
mehr selbst im denken und es gibt
menschen die zuhören und sagen dass wir
jungen recht haben
es ist eine großartige chance in diesen
prozess eingebunden zu sein und unser
zusammenleben zu verbessern vielleicht
sollten wir alle die grenzen
überschreiten die wir uns gesetzt haben
so können wir unser land vorwärtsbringen
diesen tatendrang und diese zuversicht
will die deetzer nutzen ab in eine neue
zukunft
ich wollte schon immer im sommer bob
schlitten fahren
[Musik]
beinahe 30 projekte unterstützt die
dezent bosnien fördert demokratische
strukturen oder die gleichberechtigung
der geschlechter orgasmus die über jahre
gepflegt werden die kriegsvergangenheit
zu überwinden dieses ziel bleibt im
fokus
in diesem psychiatriezentrum investiert
die db seien die psychische gesundung
der bevölkerung das gold um die leute
oder projektoren sind das kollektive
trauma latentes familien aus dorf als
stadt und der karibik sehr schwierig
große rolle
und das braucht hilfe von psychiatern
ganz verliebt und die hetze nicht darauf
warten
nur nicht nur und darum die
unterstützung wie es geht nicht nur um
diejenigen was erlebt haben sondern auch
die nächste wenn man mutter oder vater
risch und durch ihr gar nicht dann
überträgt man das auf eine generation
das heißt das trauma das ist nie fertig
und dann gab es auch verhaltensstörungen
auch persönlichkeitsstörungen
alkoholprobleme eigentlich auch
affektive störungen das war es hat sich
eigentlich auf die nächste generation
übertragen
[Musik]
um zur nächsten station an der grenze zu
gelangen ist es zeit abschied zu nehmen
[Musik]
die reise geht weiter an die eu
außengrenze nach b hutchins auffanglager
lieb
[Musik]
eigentlich schon
pieper hat in den vergangenen jahren
traurige berühmtheit erlangt das camp
war nicht winterfest die unterbringung
der migranten katastrophal
gemeinsam mit dem schweizer botschafter
informiert sich patricia dunn c vor ort
über die humanitäre lage
trotz anwesenheit von lokalen medien und
sicherheitsleuten versucht dann sie sich
ein möglichst authentisches bild zu
machen
ich hasse es in die kameras kommen die
leute fühlen sich ausgestellt das will
ich nicht
sie sollen sich frei fühlen zu reden
[Musik]
die migranten kommen mehrheitlich aus
afghanistan bangladesch und pakistan
sind sie vom süden haben sie ihre
familie zurückgelassen
sie gingen allein eine ziemlich leise
hoffen wir dass alles gut wird
die schweiz hat ein migrations abkommen
mit bosnien herzegowina
es ist immer gut zu sehen wie junge
frauen sich engagieren und was sie
daraus machen
deshalb sind wir hier wir arbeiten für
eine bessere zukunft
danke für alles was sie machen behalten
sie die motivation
die jungen männer haben bereits eine
lange und beschwerliche reise hinter
sich
das personal kommt vom zentrum in bi hat
am wochenende sind es freiwillige
[Musik]
was ist das hauptproblem schmerzen
sie kommen mit offenen wunden von der
polizei an der kroatischen grenze oft
verarztet das gesundheitspersonal
menschen die an der grenze
zurückgewiesen mit so genannten push
bergs brutal zurück gestoßen wurden
und es ist sicher besser organisiert
außen vor
das migrationsproblem ist das größtes
problem die migrations krise aber ist
ein politisches ein gesamteuropäisches
problem
ich würde es sehr schätzen wenn die
polizei nicht immer so nahe wäre die
ganze zeit
sie muss mich nicht beschützen
genau
bei der essensausgabe müssen die
migranten ihre ausweise zeigen damit sie
sich nicht mehrmals täglich an stellen
das jeden tag
ich meine abstand halten händewaschen
ich meine es ist hilfe zur selbsthilfe
wir versuchen es nicht genügend masken
vorhanden
masken sind schon vorhanden aber sie
benutzen sie nicht die einhaltung von
kobe schutzmaßnahmen ist nur eines von
vielen problemen im auffanglager
probierte begrenzt
natürlich nicht funktioniert in front
hunger und sind sehr viele junge niemann
und bändigen
wir würden gerne schauen was sich
verbessert hat
aber nur wenn es okay ist für sie wir
haben viele probleme hier das wasser ist
ein problem und die toiletten sind ein
größeres problem
ich bin seit zwei monaten hier wasser
toiletten
[Musik]
dann nehmen wir das machen wird das geld
um die behandlung von menschen wo vieles
auf 9
[Musik]
der wahnsinn
das ist super aber im vergleich mit dem
oscar ist es sicher besser das heißt das
braucht langfristig ist die stimme ist
die andere dass das land die die
eigenschaften und kapazität des
migrations stromausfällen
das passiert nicht von heute auf morgen
und der bruch langfristige
zusammenarbeit
die hände zustand und getriezt übernahm
[Musik]
die migrations krise wird die region
noch länger beschäftigen
die unterstützung der deetzer ist eine
hilfe aber keine lösung
patricia tanze und die reisegruppe
verlassen das land um von der schweiz
aus die migrationsfrage weiter anzugehen
[Musik]
ich bin optimistisch dann kommt das
community ist depressiv sofort also ich
denke dass das jahresende ist handys
zeigt dass man das wirklich auch es geht
darum prioritäten setze und dass man
nicht einfach drin sagt ja dass ich
jetzt halt
gott ist wieder eine macht ist keine
option
herzlich willkommen natürlich stand sie
kolleginnen die wir hier mit mir sind
geschätzte mitglieder dieser kommission
unter der leitung von patricia ganze
hilft die schweiz weiterhin mit die
probleme in der internationalen
zusammenarbeit anzupacken
aber wir machen das beste aus den
umständen wie sie wie sie haben
[Musik]